and welcome back to the realist podcast
in the dunya and also the best podcast
in the dunya thank you son of allah
today i'm joined with me myself and i
alhamdulillah the three top tier man me
myself
because the other brothers charizard and
uh
allah
they're uh
they're busy alhamdulillah
inshallah doing the work of allah
alhamdulillah
so it's just myself today alhamdulillah
special treat for myself and a special
treat for you guys insha'allah
how am i doing today
i'm doing good i'm doing good you see i
have my nice background starting to look
nice and cute
alhamdulillah
yeah you can call it an adventure yeah
for sure i've been a bit of an adventure
for sure
i am you rush arsene that was that was
funny that was funny
may allah bless three muslim brothers
broadcast as all people matter
i mean
from sudan allah sound like i met one
guy honestly i'll never forget this
brother he just he's he's just so nice
masha allah i met him in high school we
went that catholic school by the way but
he was he was sudanese masha allah a
muslim guy and he was so cool i wish i
still had this contact bro every so
often i remember him i'm like i wish i
could message him
our lady at subscribe carmel
catholic school
reach out to my instagram insha allah
reach out to my instagram i'd love to uh
connect
alhamdulillah
is there a twist stream to our only
youtube only youtube exclusively youtube
uh not because of a sponsorship because
we're just not on uh we're just not on
twitch
can i guess where they are or is it a
secret uh it's not i don't know if it's
a secret but it's not for me to say so i
don't know i don't care if you guess
mars or jupiter i'm not going to say yes
or no
uh but i'll leave it up to speculation
inshallah
allah the main man you and um you and
anthony are like aunt west are like the
dynamic duo of the comment section
and of course we have uh
sam
hashimi
which is not her name but i see she
updated her profile picture
uh but you should put it back to
whatever it was before
the two brothers masha allah they are
busy
too busy for you very clearly um
so it's just me alhamdulillah and you
guys are
you specifically very very very blessed
to see just me it's going to be like one
of my tick tock streams here
alhamdulillah
uh
thumbs down or up i don't know if you're
just wishy washy or if you're asking me
i would say thumbs up 100
my favorite country i don't have a
favorite country i have a favorite
nation and that is the ummah of
rasulallah
that is my favorite nation of all time
and it will forever be the best
nation latest book that i've read it's
called
the ruling system of islam that's what
it's called
3 am masha allah may allah bless you
immensely
malik being humble masha allah may allah
bless you my brother
all right
so
where am i from i live in canada but i'm
from palestine alhamdulillah
i'm going to try and keep up with all
the comments here all right uh
1208 i'm assuming that's p.m in london
yeah five hours ahead masha'allah may
allah bless you for staying up late it's
not quite three in the morning like the
other person but you know inshallah it's
the thought that counts am i from
toronto yes
i'm from toronto
am i currently there right now no but i
am from there
romney has an afghanistan fundraiser and
his tick tock bio donate to it yes this
is my tick tock bio and this is my
instagram bio
so go check it out donate i think we're
almost halfway there what the goal is i
don't know if it was raised
recently from the brother who organized
it
but we'll see insha'allah
how do you get such a dope background
what's your setup so uh
i got two flood lights flod flood lights
uh they come with a little remote so you
can change the color so if i want to
make it green i can i'll change it make
it green
i can make it basically whatever color i
want
i just kind of turned it off there red
you know whatever i can do whatever i
want with it it's pretty cool
you just try and match the colors
which i'm not very good at but
regardless good enough
that's going to bother you for the rest
of the stream you guys but khalas it is
what it is and um i have a light here
soft light i have a fill light here
and uh that's basically the setup i also
have like a
a projector screen this right here it's
a projector screen just to absorb the
light and actually be honest this is
kind of bothering me too
so let me uh
i think
good enough
okay
all right back to the actual stream
advice for a black brother struggling to
marry may allah bless you immensely i
can't help you
you can't help yourself only allah can
bless you with something like that my
friend
but practically what you can do to
better your chances obviously i know you
have probably been making dua but make
lots of
and man it's all about networking
you as a man you know you got to make
sure you are at a good place
you're confident you're outgoing you
know you're the man i'm and you know i
think nothing less of you you masha
allah you look like a very you know fit
brother masha allah
just go for it man go network ask around
if you have brothers who are married ask
them to ask their wives
and uh just network and honestly bro
when when it comes to you it's gonna
feel like subhanallah yesterday she
wasn't here now she's here you know
that's amazing so keep making dua don't
lose hope and just be certain that allah
will grant you a pious wife
may allah grant you his wife
i mean
all right
let's see
an ayah that left an impact on you
actually the one that left an impact on
me recently was with sheikh uthman ebin
allah bless him when we had him on the
stream subhanallah he was uh
talking about the in the quran
says he created death and life to test
uh which of us is best in deeds
and when he said that some scholars in
their tafsir in their tafaser they say
that when allah says death he's
referring to this life and when he says
life is referring to the afterlife that
just struck my soul it struck my soul
right here it just struck my soul man
and you guys can see my reaction i was
like
damn that like it hurts in a good way
you know what i mean
like this is death this life is actually
death and the only thing that's promised
in this life is death subhanallah it's
like
it's amazing and ayah
that always sticks with me i think i
think i mentioned in a video we we
recorded recently was when the prophet
said remember often the destroyer of all
pleasures
he was talking about death but he didn't
say death he said remember often the
destroyer of all pleasures why did he
wear it like that because think i want
everyone to think of something that
makes them happy
think of something that makes you happy
your family
the idea of getting married the idea of
being rich the idea of something in this
life nothing that has to do with gender
right
think about anything in this life
now remember that you're gonna die one
day
how do you
feel don't feel happy anymore when i
think about about getting married and
being rich and being successful you know
it makes me feel happy you know i'm a
human being i think we all are and we
all have that one thing that makes us
feel happy like you know that would be
good
when you think of death all that goes
away it's like it's nothing
because it destroys your pleasure
it ruins all your plans you want to get
married well you're dead you can't
you want to be successful you're dead
you can't and obviously the only success
in this life is pleasing allah
and attaining a high rank in jannah but
that's why i said make it of something
make it something of this you know of
this world
um i'm gonna
i'm gonna skip through a lot of comments
uh with hamza it's going to come later
on inshallah in the month maybe a few
weeks down the line
um do i speak arabic unfortunately no i
don't i'm learning alhamdulillah in
quranic arabic again no i don't but i'm
learning alhamdulillah
great class
you were definitely the uh one of the
star students of that class
f-l-o-o-d is that not what i said
f-l-o-o-d
oh floods man can spell but mans can't
read i can spell but i can't read i
thought you said men's can't spell
[Laughter]
it's always torturous to have you in my
stream i'm gonna start ignoring your
comments okay i'm sorry i have to skip
through a lot of comments get back to
the the bottom
uh
for the i think that's two
i'm gonna say euros or is it pounds i
don't know two currency of some nations
what's your opinion on our opinion
what what is your opinion on
i always struggle saying it
beautiful question
i love them for the sake of allah i
think they're doing great work masha
allah
really focusing on the
spiritual side and going out and giving
dawah and stuff i think they do great
work
i think they do need to get a little
more political
and push for
more the more political part of islam
because they kind of frame in a way like
come to islam because we're spiritual
and we have this beautiful spirituality
it's true but it's not the whole thing
they're missing the part about the the
politics the legislation
they're missing a big chunk of that so
may allah bless them for their work
i mean i think they need to start
incorporating that
i'm a paid member you can't ignore me
watch watch me watch me ignore you
join the spelling bee you know i
i mean i struggled spelling squirrel in
grade four and ever since then i just
never even thought i would ever
uh try and spell anything ever again but
unfortunately you know you kind of have
to
jake the muslim
metaph metaphysician you guys are
messing me up man you guys are messing
me up the muslim metaphysician may allah
bless him i love the brother so much um
inshallah i have his contact so i will
reach out to him inshaallah i think it'd
be great to have them on
i think we're all hyped man honestly
we're all hyped uh not yet not now i
just got back to the gym i'm gonna work
out a little bit and once i'm at a
decent place i'm gonna start with mma
inshallah inshallah
i'm bodybuilding and entrepreneur
alhamdulillah and thanks for the advice
my guy keep grinding have you may allah
elevate you unless you masha allah so he
is a fake guy masha'allah was right
squirrel is absolutely mad this bell i
know you used autocorrect for that i
know you relied on autocorrect for that
i would too
rami are you dyslexic sometimes
salaam brother recently started watching
your show
love from the uk
may allah allah bless you honestly
how to balance between seeking knowledge
and college slash work
it's difficult
but it's possible
eve like let's say you work so much and
you work so hard that you only have
about two hours of free time in a week
make one hour just to chill by yourself
to relax to recuperate
and make the other hour to seek
knowledge
at the very least if not an hour and a
half to acknowledge and half an hour to
rest
but there's always time make sure you
have time and the best way to do is to
commit to some kind of class the i3
institute offers free lessons it's two
hours a week
and there's different time slots
different classes different instructors
and it's only two hours a week i'm sure
everyone can fit that into their
schedule
rami what do you think of the
eschatology of sheikh ibrahim hussein i
don't know i i didn't
hear what he said about
eschatology or
his eschatological beliefs if that's a
word
my friend is
i don't know if i should say that word
on the stream because they might just
flag the stream
but my friend is
um
homo sapien
and uh
tg
is it okay well what do you mean is it
okay in islam it's haram
in islam
that doesn't mean you know you hate him
or you don't like to be you know
close to them or anything that you know
a lot of very very disrespectful people
say it's nothing like that
as muslims we have akida we have our
fair based on our aki that we have our
fear what does allah say
it's haram both of them the actions of
both is haram therefore it's not okay
from the same perspective
he is muslim but i have thought about it
a lot i do not know if it is right sorry
for commenting multiple times it's on my
mind it was skipped
uh
don't worry don't don't worry i didn't
skip on purpose i just kind of skipped
um yes i said homo sapien on purpose
because if i said the actual term then
it would be flagged as well so i'm not
gonna say that but regard thank you you
know i i'm gonna get back to this but i
wanna highlight this he's not a sheikh
stop asking for questions thank you may
allah bless you i'm not a fakie i'm not
a scholar or fair i can't answer these
questions except if i know in this case
it's a very clear-cut answer i do know
i do know the answer to this um
can't find the comment now
here
i do not answer that alhamdulillah it's
haram the actions are haram and if the
person believes it's halal then they're
not a muslim
if they believe it's haral they're not a
muslim because it's explicit in the
quran
of the prophet
so if they believe it's okay they're
making
and that is a sin
and that actually takes them out of the
fold of islam
the sin itself is one thing
but acting as if it's not a sin that's
that's a different level
okay another question if i i haven't
read this yet if i don't know the answer
i don't know the answer i might just say
i don't know ask a scholar move on
romney can you please answer this what
is islamic rulings on the wife wanting
to work but her fiance says if she works
he wants
them to own everything together shared
account to put our salaries in
i mean he could they could do that but
he doesn't have a right to her money
that doesn't mean he can spend from her
money
let's say they both have the same job
and make the same amount of money let's
say they both make you know
fifty thousand dollars a year
um he can only touch his 50 000 he can't
touch hers unless she says you can touch
it and it's like basically a subtle call
for her because she does she's not
obligated to spend on
you know
basically like the basic needs and all
that stuff so she helps with those
payments and stuff to take care of them
it's a subtle sadhaka for her
but he doesn't have access unless she
says he does so it's not his right to
say you need to do this no because allah
says he needs to do it it's not his
right to put it on to his wife
unless she you know is okay with it
what advice do you have for someone with
no friends living in the west struggling
to find good friends upon allah it's
difficult it is difficult and first i
want to say until you find good friends
you have to make the quran and the
hadith and the videos of islam you have
to make that your best friend that has
to be your 24 7. that has to be your
influence in life
because it's difficult but
go to the masjid and befriend all the
muslims there on friday general befriend
as many people as possible make them
similar to you your age um and that
stuff even if it makes it if it makes it
easier your ethnicity you know if you're
black fine black brothers in the masjid
if you're white find white brothers in
the masjid if it'll help you relate to
them more if it doesn't matter go for
you know whoever a young brother
or if you're a sister or young sister go
say salaam alaikum touch base with them
they probably have muslim friends and
then you can integrate into the group in
sha allah but the best way to do it
especially on short notice is to join
the i3 institute you'll be put in a
class you'll have classmates there
inshallah
is there a big islamic community in
toronto and shall i may visit next year
there is actually it over
over like the surrounding areas as well
there's a pretty good muslim community
here alhamdulillah
what do i think about mortgages my
shaykh says is haram regardless no
matter what
mortgages are haram
browser difference between reading the
quran and watching youtube for sites i
think allah is calling me
if you believe allah is calling you then
consider it i'll call from allah spent
because let's say even if it's not even
if it's like in your head for some weird
reason it's still a good thing but never
think that i always think if you feel
something that is from allah consider it
from allah so long as it is halal
otherwise consider it from shaitaan
there is a difference if you allah not
allah the prophet he said that allah
will reward a person for reciting the
quran even down to every letter he said
each of those is a letter elif is a
letter lam is a letter meme is a letter
and each of them get you a reward and if
you struggle you get double the reward
listening to recitation is still
rewardable one hundred percent but it's
not the same as you're setting it
yourself
that's what mashiach has taught
so i hope that helps inshallah
and guys uh if if you want to like if
you have a very important question you
need it answered the best way to do it
is to send a super chat because i'm i
have a lot of comments here i'm just one
guy and i'm trying to answer all of
these if you know if i know the answer
how do you guys come in contact with
hamza i'm not sure i'm i really don't
know to be honest because i don't really
reach out to the people unless i have a
personal you know relationship with them
good any good online institutions
acknowledge the i3 institute
is uh
sam hashimi still in here can you type
i3 institute.ca so they have inshallah
brother
how do you promise allah you won't
repeat a sin
when you're certain you will repeat it i
usually tell allah i will try my best to
stay away from it allah bless you for
your sincerity your issue is not
promising allah your issue is
being certain you're going to repeat it
you have you have
discipline problems you're not
disciplined enough to know you'll never
do it again
or to at least say that i will never do
it again and that's that's what you need
to work on to be able to stay away from
it
you should have the intention of never
doing it again
or at least doing your best 100 and
that's a beautiful thing again may allah
bless you for that but your first first
issue is not being able to stay away
from it
you have to make yourself stay away from
it somehow
and you know different
different things different addictions
they're triggered at different points
for different people you know if it's a
certain certain type of sin that's
common amongst men
if you're like let's say it happens at a
certain time of day
uh whenever you're like alone
in your house or in your room
then make sure at that time of day
you're not alone in your house in your
room
things like that
you have to be certain
you have to be certain
but it's a good thing mashallah that
you're sincere
i don't know if lucid dreaming is halal
i know i don't know
i just want to make sure i got all the
super chats and i didn't miss any i
think there were only two so far
yeah
all right
to everyone who said salaam
romney if you mix your face with five
you get on hell
what what what goes on in your mind
what's going on in your head
how do you just think of something like
that
and i32 right here
you forgot the dot ca but it's this it's
i3 institute
dot ca
that's a great online islamic
institution
is great for quran studies 100
100 prob honestly i don't know most of
them are all of them but probably the
best in the game honestly
when is the podcast dropping what do you
mean the podcast like we haven't been
podcasting for like over a year now you
mean what you mean the humza podcast in
shotline a few weeks should be should be
down uh and uploaded in a few weeks
how should i respond to comments like
you've become too religious or you're
very strict on religion now it makes me
uncomfortable for some reason it should
make you uncomfortable
because that's a very dumb thing to say
what what what does two religious is
there such thing as too religious
what does that mean and you know firstly
i wouldn't even speak with these people
i wouldn't even speak with them anyone
who says you're because i mean the the
you being very strict with religion
that's one thing
maybe some people are too strict and
they're saying things that's actually
not true
and they're being strict on other people
that's possible but if you're praying
your five salah in the sunnah in in um
water and
people can't really come below or you're
too extreme you're too strict you're
i mean there was one instance where uh
one sahabah i think it was a sahabi
who stood up all night in prayer and the
prophet said like what is this
only do what you can handle so in that
case
be consistent with your stuff and do
what you can handle but there's no such
thing as being too religious that's a
really dumb statement that honestly
liberals use to try and demean religious
people like you're too religious
what the heck does that even mean and if
you do want to engage with i don't think
you should engage with them but if you
do ask how am i too religious you pray
five times a day how's that to religious
that's actually the bare minimum i think
you're the issue here i think you're the
problem you can't you can't bring
yourself to uh
you know pray five times a day but you
can get starbucks 24 times in a week
i hope that was a good answer inshallah
um i appreciate it a lot and i'm sure
the other two brothers will very much as
well
rami's 19 that's not true actually
i'm somewhere above 11 though for sure
rami is a beautiful person though may
allah bless him i mean may allah bless
me but honestly i'm
i i i only pointed this up i brought
this up because i say this a lot my tic
tac i don't i don't want to hear any
praise you know
i don't think i should hear any praise
get any praise i'm not praise worthy at
all to be honest to be completely honest
i don't deserve any praise and
i don't want to end up getting arrogant
you know what i mean so i'm nothing i'm
just another dude on the internet i'm no
better than any of you i'm sure you all
are very beautiful people masha allah
elevate you all immensely
going overseas technology it's a
beautiful thing inshallah
like going studying at the university of
medina it's beautiful why not
favorite sahaba
or saba you resonate with the most the
one i
i used to be musabe
and he's definitely up there
uh but now abu bakr and omar dillahu and
whom they're like taking the cake
and i want to tell you guys a few
stories about abu bakr and um
when they were going to go on an
expedition they were going to go to a
battle to war
the prophet islam islam he asked who's
going to donate for the sake of allah
who's going to donate to allah and his
messenger
i'm paraphrasing a bit but that's
basically what he asked
and um omar was like this is the day i'm
going to be abu bakr abu bakr is the
best but today's the day i'm going to
beat him right
so um
he goes he gets half of his stuff and he
brings it to the processor and the
prophet islam he asks them
what did you bring
what have you brought with you today
he says i brought half of my stuff
and then abu bakr comes and by the way
this narration is being narrated by omar
right he's the one talking about it and
then abu bakr comes and then the process
he doesn't ask you he doesn't ask abu
bakr what did you bring
he asked abu bakr what did you leave
behind
omar he asked what did he bring abu bakr
he asked what did you leave
behind and what did he say
he said i left behind allah and his
messenger
which means he brought every single
thing he owned for the sake of allah
he's
you know
the best or one of the best
three muslims discord i think we're
we're gonna work on it soon in sha allah
what's your take on being red pilled
life has become unaffordable marriages
falling apart left right and center and
many kids now born with issues yeah i
keep
uh
pushed by family to find a wife you're
pushed by a family to find a way there's
nothing wrong with finding a wife bro
things are unaffordable right
marriages are being broken unfortunately
that doesn't mean you don't get married
that doesn't mean you don't get married
you should get married it's encouraged
it's not haram if you don't but it's
encouraged to
uh just do your due diligence to find a
good woman well first do your due
diligence to make sure you're a good man
but then do your due diligence to make
sure you find a good woman a good wife
insha allah and what do we look for
character in deen
first time i answer that question my
take on being red pill
forget red pill man forget it it's a
half
half done i don't want to say anything
you know bad or haramba it's a half done
broken philosophy that is based on
getting women
why why is your goal to get women why is
that your only goal in life make your
goal to please allah spent and you will
find goodness in life
because allah never tells you anything
that's not good for you so make islam
your philosophy make islam your
make islam your make islam your deen
is a full system of life no room for red
pill there are some things they they
believe in red pill that's in line with
them 100
there's a few arguments that red pill
uses that if you use it in islam it also
helps islam's case okay that doesn't
mean you have to be red pill the same
thing with feminism there are some
things they believe in feminism that's
not islam and there are things that
aren't there there are things that take
you out of the fold of islam same thing
with reptil forget red pill
forget it man it's a waste of time study
islam
the prophet
if you if you take red pill to mean like
the truth the prophet was repealed
before any of us
because he got the truth from allah to
allah and uh that truth is islam so
forget red pill it's a dumb term it's
dumb it's overused it's annoying you
have a lot of stupid red pill
fake fake male masculine dominant
wannabe
uh soy boys who were given a mic
unfortunately and say very very
disgusting disingenuous stuff
and very few of them are academic at all
by the way very few of them
so just study islam in sha allah
there's a super chat somewhere i have to
find it where is it here
did you see the debate between daniel
and feminist lady
if yes what is your opinion on it um
[Music]
i did not see it unfortunately i didn't
uh so i i don't know what you're talking
about i'm sure it's an interesting
debate but i personally didn't see it
and that's someone translate that for me
it's going to bother me all night
because i want to read it
um someone translated for me man i'm not
going to sit here struggling for any
guys anymore
may allah bless you guys
the process that falsely said if there's
a prophet come after him
i'm pretty sure he said that but omar if
there were to be a prophet after me it
would have been umur
but scholars i believe scholars debate
whether this is authentic or not
when you're dyslexic in two languages
about to make it three man i'm about to
introduce french into maya
my list of languages i'm dyslexic
i was not impressed with the debate at
all dot dot feminist dot dot dot and
then these emojis
like i haven't seen it i can't say
anything
can you speak a better french no i can't
man
i can't that's my whole point i maybe i
should be able to because i'm canadian
but
i can't they tried forcing me to learn
until grade nine and they did then i
forgot everything literally right after
grade nine ended i never took another
french course again
it's watching sports haram again another
question i can't say i don't know
only answer i do know is it might be
haram for ufc because there's you know
ringside women you know guys
uh there are men showing their aura as
well like
literally they're sometimes wearing
basically like underwear
this is the man too by the way now
you know they're fighting for money
what's halal about it
um
that's just what
you know different shaykh has said that
i i
uh listen to
but go to your shaykh go to your scholar
about it and don't ask me if your
questions or ask me but expect i don't
know as an answer because i don't know
no
the i3 institute is free
it's free they don't mention it on the
website they should mention on the
website if they don't i'm pretty sure
they do but if they don't it's it's
because it's free there's no price tag
on it
am i still studying snap of course of
course
it has slowed down unfortunately but
uh you know your journey and studying
stamina never ends
your brawn lames
do you select the questions to ask well
whichever i literally just skim over
them and i land on one and if it's not
anything crazy the night
i answer it
the way to learn other languages is to
not be embarrassed to speak it and know
that you're not a native or going to be
a linguist
talk to people that are familiar too
that's that's great
that is
great great i'm still not speaking every
to you guys well that's great
do you know the easy peasy method i
don't know that is attention check bro
you monitoring me man are you on hell
bro
i think you should message me about this
insha allah
because
it depends honestly on what you mean
if you mean wholeheartedly like okay
that's a big issue you need to deal with
that inshallah
uh you need to deal with that so message
me on instagram
uh romney choose aaron the beast titan
man
i gotta go with aaron
i gotta go with aaron
thank you thank you
romney would you be half your height or
double your weight double my weight bro
don't cause double my weights like it's
like nothing man
double my weights like nothing honestly
i'm and i can always you know work out
and not convert it to muscle because
that's not how it works but
just work out
mommy watch his enemy
i never said i watch anime
i just said aaron over the beast titan i
can be familiar with that watching man
i'm not gonna put the full comment but
brother ask any tips
on beard growth because my brother i'm
18 and everyone says be patient but
really any tips
uh you know what let me shout out my
brother
right now if you go to abu beard
it's a b o o b e a r d abu beard he has
a website he sells beard products he
sells derma rollers and i'm it's not
even fully in for me yet but he sells
drummer rollers which you roll in your
face
growth serum beard uh serum has
different like like lavender and vanilla
in different scents and stuff
and uh that will help derma roller bro
will take you all the way man all the
way you roll it all over your face put
growth serum
i went from like having no facial hair
to alhamdulillah what i have now uh
because of the derma roller and stuff so
use that insha allah you'll be good
salam
long hair rami rest is short i think i'm
somewhere good in the middle
like a little longer than this and cut
properly and well done which is not
right now
i think that's like prime
i actually accidentally clicked on that
thing that comment
and then i put it down because i didn't
know what it said and i'm like it can't
be that bad i put it up and i'm like i
shouldn't have put that up
and i'll also put this man in a timeout
sit in the corner and think about what
you did you're in a timeout
how often you use a derma roller um for
me i find the best the most success with
it the best results when it's not every
single day
i do it like maybe look it up i don't
know i can't say anything but for me
when i do it every so often maybe a few
times a week two three times a week i
find the best results
am i still an electrician you must be an
og
who who are you
because you need you must have known me
before my tick tock in in youtube and
instagram days because this was old
school stuff man i'm not anymore
alhamdulillah
but that's old school days man
my eyes look sad but my heart is happy
it's not all that matters
i'm not gonna shout out your tick tock
what a shameless plug how dare you
sarah asks
what is your favorite trait in your wife
i'm not married
not yet
i'll let you know when i get married
inshallah
am i in dental school i'm not in dental
school i can tell you you never knew me
a day in your life may love bless you
um
what's the name of the product for beard
growth it's abu beard hill type it
here
abu beard
look it up insha'allah
brother is complete happiness attainable
in this world no it's not
it will it's not and it will never be no
one can fully 100
be happy
ever
even if you feel super happy in a moment
you can't attain it wholeheartedly
at any point in time
you can be happy from time time yeah but
you'll never completely be happy
over any
extensive period of time
it's not possible
and that's why
it's important to aim for jannah because
you'll always be happy in jannah
here it's impossible to feel happy all
the time in jannah and simp it's
impossible to not be happy all the time
that's the goal inshaallah
yes i had ice cap today it tasted like
peanut butter or butter again
it tastes like peanut butter i even
talked to my word saying that
tastes like peanut butter unfortunately
what games what games do i play i don't
play no games man
i'm serious i'm a serious guy i never
play any games
sometimes i play ballerina i play chess
sometimes too
no i used to play cod back in the day a
lot
it actually tasted pretty good if i'm
being honest it wasn't that bad
foreign our other half here masha'allah
basketball i love basketball i love
playing basketball i don't play very
often i'm not that great anymore but
who do i main and valerie i don't even
remember the name it's
what's the name
it's the one that can like dash
and like
jump up and throw like the little clouds
jet
jet
where are fired and on hillary i told
you told you guys wants to tell you guys
again
that is confidential information man
confidential i can't say where they are
you can ask them
i can't say where they are
honestly i don't even personally know
exactly where they are at this point
yeah chad
you guys are right thank you
yes exactly exactly i wrote something
about this
on this before
happiness when people say they're
looking to be happy they're looking for
the wrong thing
happiness is just a feeling
contentment is a state that you can
enter you can enter us you can't enter a
state of happiness you can only feel
happy you can enter a state of
contentment that will result in
happiness because you're content
and you're grateful
and think about it if you're poor you'll
you'll be content
when you get 100 a month you'll be like
oh my god this is amazing because you
just came from poverty
but if you expect a million dollars a
year and you're not anywhere close to
that you're never going to be content
because you have such high standards if
allah never wills that for you you're
never going to be grateful you're never
going to be happy
it's it's important to think about that
insha allah
allah someday soon
as well as t3 and merch insha allah
dropping soon
so stay tuned for that
true peace and contentment through the
verse of allah yes 100
there are other things like a pie spice
that will be the coolness of your eyes
that will allow you to feel cool but
true to heart peace and contentment
wholeheartedly for an extended period of
time can only come from allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala
i don't even know your name to put your
name on it you have different social
media names
you're silly you're silly
how to have more gratitude i always take
things for granted stop taking things
for granted just start thinking allah
for every little thing
when you're laying in your bed and
you're comfortable in your comforters
and under your blanket
just thank allah for that comfort
because there are people that don't have
it
when you're able to watch uh you know a
live stream like this and get some insha
allah reminders that are good
you know thank allah that you have a
device to be able to be here
and say alhamdulillah that you also have
internet to be able to watch it just say
alhamdulillah for everything
and know that you don't deserve anything
know that you don't own anything know
that you don't deserve anything
everything is from allah everything
returns to allah eventually will die
my stuff's not coming with me you're not
your stuff's not coming with you
and even if it did you can't do anything
with it
so
just remember you don't actually own
anything
be thankful to allah for giving it to
you
that's a beautiful tip as well i forgot
to mention that very beautiful tip
a says try to imagine that the blessings
you have right now are gone
your home everything etc try to imagine
it as as good as you can as clearly as
you can
exactly
exactly
the story of barcis yeah i do the uh the
jewish like scholar rabbi
yeah
it's a very scary story
very scary may allah protect us from
that
i think it's a good story to link with
avoiding free mixing environments 100
100
maybe i'll end on the story take two or
three comments and then i'll end the
stream insha allah
but barcista was a very well-known i
believe jewish scholar everyone had very
high regards for him he was just very
well known everyone basically really
liked him and eventually i think two or
three brothers came to him and said you
know we need someone to take care of her
sister while we're gone while we're
traveling can you do that and he said
okay
so first what he did
was he would prepare food and like leave
it maybe like down the hall or far from
her she would he would leave she would
get it he would leave it at the door
and then eventually he started knocking
and giving it to her
and then eventually started knocking
going in giving it to her then he
started knocking going in talking to her
slowly slowly slowly moving moving
unfortunately getting closer and closer
to zinnia because allah says don't go
anywhere near zana
he just says don't go anywhere near it
every step he took might have seemed
like a small step but it was closer and
closer to a big mistake
and then eventually they ended up
committing xena and then she got
pregnant
and then
he killed both the mother and the child
and buried them
and the brothers came back and then they
saw a dream about it that their their
their sister and the daughter were
buried
or a sister and the child were buried at
a certain place but what did this what
did the guy tell them he told them that
she died from a sickness and he made a
fake grave for her
so they went to the real one where they
saw the dream and they found her and
they found the baby
and then they reported him
and they dragged him to basically
execute him to kill him for what he
did
and then shaytan comes to him
shaitaan comes to this man while he's
being dragged away to be executed
and he says
varsity i'm shaytan
i'm the one who got you in this mess
i'm the only one who can get you out
if you want to get out of this mess
worship me
pray to me
and i'll save you
so he did he prayed to shaitaan
and then shaitaan left him
the last thing he did before he died was
pretty [ __ ] on
allah
so many beautiful lessons you can learn
from this
about free mixing about taking steps
towards you know
major major major sins
about you can never be you know so high
that is you can't fall
was this not because he isolated himself
i don't know maybe he
he didn't want to get married and he
didn't you know
you know basically go out with people or
see anyone and and that contributed to
allah maybe
but the main point is that he took small
steps towards a big mistake
and he was he he constantly went free
mixing and avoided what allah
you know taught humanity to do
i can kind i mean you guys saw like i
can kind of read and then i struggle
some many points so i can't fully read i
can't fully write i can read a few
things i can write a few things but it's
really really broken
a story scares me
being i've always been a loner
i mean being alone is not necessarily a
bad thing
it could be a really good thing a lot of
the time
um
unless it's going gonna lead you to do
haram
then it's a bad thing
um
but if that's what worries you then you
know work to be more social
and there are different ways to do it
but work to be more social inshallah
last thing i'm going to answer before in
the stream in sha allah
i'm new here and was interested on how
the three muslims started
i'm not going to talk about fayad and
angel
but they met before i met either of them
they were the first two out of the three
to meet
i forget how i think fire reached out to
on hill and then they spoke and they
decided to go on a trip to iceland
um
and then they you know they were friends
but this was when angel was you know not
you know he still wasn't a muslim he
wasn't a muslim at this point
and then
i was at the gym
back when i lived in mississauga
and also back on fire in mississauga and
i saw this guy doing tricep uh
pull-downs
so
i asked for advice uh he said he was a
fit guy
i saw he's a fake guy he knows what he's
doing clearly so i go up to him i'm like
you know hey man don't mean to interrupt
can you show me how to do this with
proper form because i kept putting i
kept doing it in a way where i would
feel it in my shoulders and that's not
right because you need to feel any
triceps obviously
so
he showed me alhamdulillah he gave me
some other tips and then we were talking
and i
i said something like oh you know
masha'allah allah something like that
alhamdulillah something like that
stepped up you know i'm a muslim it
steps up
he's like oh you're muslim i'm like yeah
what about you he's like yeah me too
and then
we talked or met once or twice after
that and then he invited me to go on a
trip to alberta to banff i'm like
let's do it then we went to benf
and uh in banffy actually we were
driving and he mentioned the idea of
starting a podcast i'm like that'd be
amazing that would be great
let's do it
and then later on
they were speaking with alfred and angel
were speaking with another friend they
had
and then they invited me to be on the
call to kind of give dao and answer some
of the questions he had
alhamdulillah i was really honored to
you know to have that
you know
um
privilege alhamdulillah i joined and i
saw unhealth for the first time he just
accepted islam too
so
alhamdulillah
i uh
alhamdulillah i joined we spoke then we
kept talking after that as the three of
us
and we we had a lot uncommon
alhamdulillah we were very like-minded
we were all very
uh you know social and well-spoken
people alhamdulillah alhamdulillah from
allah then we just decided to start a
podcast and we did
i think angel decided on the name of
three muslims t3m or in the rest is
history alhamdulillah
yeah when i lost my thought i will
something
it will happen
okay mrs sam
hashimi like you're any more creative
you
is it possible for a person to have
dreams and or visions that come true
or is that evil no it's not evil
it's possible the prophet ali
is that the last surviving peace of
prophethood are
dreams so allah sometimes he gives
humans dreams sometimes it's it's uh you
know glad tidings sometimes it's a
warning
allah tells you a lot of the time it's
symbolic like you might see a white
shirt and it represents your amen
your your conviction in allah and in
islam
sometimes it happens exactly you know
you see a scene that exactly comes true
bit by bit
but that's that's more rare to see a
dream like that
i'm going to take
one more commenter question insha allah
i think this is a nice one masha allah
make god for me i'm suffering from a
functional neurological disorder
everyone make dua for our
brother or sister here
that allah grants them shifa and blessed
them immensely
and i want to see amin
all over the comments insha allah
everyone type amin
and i'm not ending the stream until i
see them
again
in a few weeks insha'allah
you will you will get it
there we go there we go masha allah all
right well they came way too fast they
all came at the same time
i mean may allah make it easier for them
i mean
i mean i mean i mean
you want a quran recitation you're
probably not going to get it
i mean i mean i mean i mean
i mean i mean i mean i mean i mean
i mean
i mean
this is what we do for our brothers and
sisters even if it's just saying i mean
we have to be united like this we have
to love each other like this we have to
care for each other like this
this is how we have to be
allah
i really strained my voice yesterday
like i really strained my voice
yesterday
but what do you think about democracy as
an as a means to an end like we live in
a non-muslim environment could we
participate in the anonymous system to
implement our deen as a means and no
there is no such thing
there is a good question but there is no
such thing there is no such thing as
implementing islam from a non-islamic
system
what you have to do is wipe out the
system and replace it with islam
democracy
what is democracy it's making man the
god
it's making man into god
man is the one who can make laws and
legislation
for themselves that's the role that god
has making legislation for people
they're trying to make themselves the
legislator they're trying to make
themselves god
so even them making the act to decide
that we should implement this system
they're coming from the wrong place they
need to submit to allah say allah is the
only one who can decide
uh you know what our way is what our
deen is and because of that
we're gonna follow islam
not
i as a human being think islam is is is
correct
and no
you as a human being you don't matter
islam is correct because it comes from
allah spent allah and allah has given us
miracles and evidence to prove that and
because we submit to allah we influence
them it does not come from socialism
capitalism
uh communism
any kind of ism
exactly it's a contradiction
exactly
i agree 100
you'll be worried if you're inside a
versailles inshallah inshallah inshallah
i'll i'll recite a little bit recite
just a little
bit but again pardon me i know the words
of allah are beautiful
but my tajweed and my voice are choppy
both of them unfortunately may allah
forgive me and make me better allah i
mean
but you know the words of allah always
the best
so insha'allah or just a little bit
let me drink some water first
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
i'm going to stop there because i don't
know the rest of it
can someone correct me please
i forget the last one
may allah forgive me
um that recitation
originally is from sheikh mensur
al-saleemi
of surah al-imran it is so beautiful it
is so beautiful
so i suggest you guys
i'll listen to that insha allah and read
uh
those ayats as well it's from surah
al-imran
but with that being said
i didn't think i'd get the one hour mark
but i did alhamdulillah it doesn't feel
like an hour but i do this all the time
at tik tok so to be expected
um
that's time that is running out all
right so allah swears by time that is
running out indeed mankind is in loss
except those
who believe
and do good works
and enjoin one another to truth and
enjoying one another to patience
and they say that if allah only revealed
this surah it would have been enough
because it covers everything
so it's very powerful
foreign